là on peut prendre un peu le ou les
essences locales nécessaires à la
constitution des sont à 300 mètres des
champs ah ben ça c'est la richesse de la
nature les arbres se reproduise donc on
va prendre au pied les beaux arbres des
arbres qui devrait attendre des années
que le gros arbres dessus face de la
lumière et on va le mettre en valeur
dans une est donc celui ci va être
notamment intéressant pour ses fleurs
pour les abeilles pour un hectare durant
cet automne la conversion des terres
agricoles en bio s'est accompagnée d'un
retour des séparations arborait entre
les parcelles
on est parti de la pointe et puis on
fait toute la parcelle jusqu'ici on en
est à deux kilomètres et le reste suit
quand même et donc on a planté 25
variétés différentes qui vont des arbres
fruitiers pommes poires cerises jusqu'à
des arbres plus intéressant pour les
abeilles comme le saule marsault un des
premiers arbres à faire du pollen à
sortie d'hiver le retour des ne sert pas
uniquement à limiter l'érosion des sols
sacré de la vie dans ses champs et
effectivement après cdc et la vo mais d
abriter des auxiliaires de culture
puisque en bio je ne mets absolument
rien en traitement qui vont des
déprédateurs pour les parasites
potentiel des cultures avec ce travail
de titan c'est km2 et à replanter le
paysan s'inscrit aussi dans son
environnement c'est aussi a le rôle de
l'agriculteur que modelé le paysage
moi j'ai la chance de pouvoir modeler le
paysage autour de moi est quand même
plus agréable d'avoir des fleurs et des
fruits que que de voir des routes là et
avec des fruitiers c'est aussi une
affaire de gourmands et on plante en
pensant aux confitures à venir